[Music]
once again Kim and Kanye's reality is
crazier than anything we could have ever
dreamed up but that's why we are here
because we're gonna clear up all the
rumors about their marriage as
Kardashians creator Ryan Seacrest opens
up to et on lines Katy Kraus scenes are
going through a lot are they in
production right now there's a lot of
rumors going around can you just set the
record straight I sure can we have not
stopped production Seacrest who's one of
the executive producers of the
Kardashians reality lineup has
first-hand knowledge of the situation
everyone's doing good everyone's doing
better on Friday there were reports that
Kim and Kanye had split and were living
apart but a source close to the couple
confirms the et that is categorically
untrue
Kim and Kanye are 100% together not only
is the rumor that they are splitting not
true but so is the report of them living
apart they are in their Bel Air home
right now the rumor mill has been
spinning out of control since November
19th when the rap icon and fashion mogul
began acting erratically in the midst of
his concert tour two days later he was
hospitalized for quote exhaustion at
UCLA Medical Center
he was released November 30th after
spending nine days there he's a
workaholic he worked
you know he needed to get his mind right
then I think everybody should respect
that and let him do that you know
Kanye's protege Teyana Taylor shined a
little light on the situation at vh1's
divas holiday concert Brooklyn take how
much time you need you know time heals
all
and as for reports that Kim is talking
with divorce lawyers our source says
absolutely false kim is talking about
having a third child reports of them
heading for a divorce couldn't be
further from the truth
[Music]
you